各位小伙伴们晚上好
我是来自中科佳和公司的黄浩
今天很高兴能参加2026CNN训练营的企业对话专场活动
跟着大家分享一些关于区域等TLE的拓展和优化的念头
2026CNN训练营不但新增了开源基础
马力全开
开发者说和企业对话的专场活动
解锁了新的直播玩法
我们一起来看一下
首先我们可以去扫码跳转到相关的EU
也来了解一些相关的互动玩法的一个详景
第一个玩法是直播开始后观看直播
在活动的EU页下方评论答题
按时间的排名
回答正确的前5名
可以领取一些精美的奖品
第二个玩法是课后作业
在直播结束之后
在EU页下评论答题
按照时间排名全部回答正确
且格式正确的前5名
可以领取定制茅台一本
然后玩法三是学习笔记和直播打卡
观看我们的CNN训练评程直播和回放
根据课程内容总结新的笔记
CNN生藤论坛和HUB开源仓库提交EU
我们也可以获得一个社区定制的礼品
好的
那我们回到本次分享的主题
切腾TLE面向生藤的拓展和优化
我们这次分享主要是
是基于三个开源生态FragOS的FragTree
的切腾变异器项目
跟华为生藤生态上的
切腾Assender的切腾插件
还有AssenderNPOI作为一个MLR的编析扩展
来做一些关于在生藤芯片上的一些算质的
深度的优化
让我们来看一下
我们基于一个比较重要的这个Base的一个
关于FragOS的一个基础设施
FragOS是一个国产芯片的统一生态软件站
不但有AI大模型
还有一些开源的库
然后我们主要依赖的是一些是FragOS
开源库中的FragTree的一个项目
那里面有很多有用的TLE扩展
能够帮助我们写
写出更好的一个Trader
Trader的一个算质
并且FragOS也有一些那个算质库
在我们去开发一些模型
或者说优化一些模型推理的时候
也是非常有用的
好了
那我们来看一下
我们本次要分享的一些四个主题内容
第一个是关于编译器的优化
我们主要是想要介绍
如何通过修改编译器
然后去使能编译器的优化能力
让原本一些没有优化到的路径
通过实能编译器的优化
修改编译器
并且使算质下落到更好更优的实现
然后提升我们算质的性能
第二个是通过添加一些TLE的Compars
一些编译提示来提示优
编译器做一些合乎我们目标预期的一些编译优化
来提升我们的算质性能
第三个是如何使用ChannelSand
NPoI提供了一套CustomOP的机制
来实现我们自己私有的定制的一些高度定制的
并且更加底层更加一些骸客的一些深度的优化
而第四个是想分享一个比较通用的TLE的拓展
来使能一些右边上的slice的操作
来提升一些数据搬运和拼接的一些load
减少一些load store来使能来使算质更加高效
好我们来结合第一个编译器的优化的一个具体的场景
来讲一讲如何进行一个编译器的优化
我们首先来看一个具体的场景吧
在一个典型的DOT加DOT的场景中
我们第一个DOT的结果作为第二个DOT的一个操作数
并且是一个唯一优质的情况下
我们原先的一个编译器的实现会是
会将第一个DOT的结果从L0c通过FixPype直接搬运到GM
然后再从GM重新load到L1
再进行第二个DOT
那么我们显然可以看到它是通过一层GM中转的
但是在升腾芯片上FixPype是具有将L0c上的数据直接搬移到L1C上的
这个硬件能力是有的
只是我们编译器没有使能这一个优化
它没有下落到这一个更加高效有效的路径上
导致了在像这种DOT加DOT类的算子
如果只是仅仅按原有的编译器来实现
它是会走一个经过一个GM的中转
它会额外的产生一些无效的农移的数据搬运的
这样是比较不好的
那我们就希望不要走这一个农移的路径
我们希望L0c就直接通过FixPype搬运到L1上
然后我们就能够节省一些GM的多余的搬运
并且显然GM搬运到L1上
它是一个带宽更小更慢的一个路径
它是一个AIC核心上片外的一个内存
然后我们在L0c直接搬运到L1
是AIC内部的一个高速度缓程
这样搬运会更快一点
好了我们来看为了实现这些目标
我们需要做一个怎样的方案设计
需要修改哪些Path
我们做这个优化主要要修改三个相关的
主要设计到了三个相关Path的修改
并且要去适配我们Ascent NPR底层的模板库
首先我们第一个需要修改的Path
就是Insert Load Store for mixCV
这个Path主要是用来
在原本编译器
在核心间的一些交互中要额外插入一些load store
比如像C核的数据要搬运到V核
那么我们CV核心之间本身是没有直接的数据通路的
我们需要将C核的数据搬运
先store到GM
再由GM重新load到UB上
这样我们就要去在编译器中插入这些CV核心之间的store和load
来使能打通AI核心中的CV或者CC之间的一个数据通路的load store来补全
然后在我们这个优化过程中我们可以发现我们直接是从L0C搬运到L1
那么我就不再需要把L0C的数据store到GM中
然后我们在这个pass中需要将无效间的cube跟cube之间的load和load插入要禁止掉
并且在L0C原本的通路中
L0C直接搬运到GM是一个NZ to ND的一个格式的转换
因为L0C是一个四维分形的格式
然后GM是一个RD的分形格式
但是我们L1上也是一个四维NZ的一个分形格式
此时我们就不需要进行一个分形格式的转换
在FixPipe的指令的DMA模式中我们也要进行一个更正
第二个需要修改的pass是graph server
就是同步相关的pass
在原本的实现中L0C上的L1上的数据全部都是从GM搬运而来
它是通过MTR这一个Pipe来进行搬运的
经过我们新增的L
由于有了我们新增的L0C到L1的通路
L1的数据来源将不仅仅只是MTR
它还有FixPipe的一个数据来源
那么我们就需要适配MMAD中的一些同步的Event
因为原先在MMAD中它都是默认数据从GM上过来的
然后我们现在打通了L0C到L1的一个数据通路
那么这也会引入FixPipe与MT之间的同路
所以在GraphServer中我们需要拓展MMAD OP中的Think-Related-Args参数来传递FixPipe
FixPipe传递使能FixPipe与MT的同步能力
通过这些Args来为后端模板库能够正确同步FixPipe跟MT做一个准备
第三个是需要修改Converter toStandard的一个Path
因为我们新增了L0C到L1的一个通路
那么我们就需要原本的FixPipe是没有相关的对应的LibCode
那我们不但要新增LibCode
而且要在Converter toStandard的一个Path中
把我们的FixPipe指定下落到我们正确新增的LibCode中
力不靠重
第四个是需要对原本的MPOIR的模板库进行一个适配与增强
我们主要是要适配MMAD的一个模板实线
因为我们引入了新的FixPipe与MT的同步
此时我们要新增相关的参数
并且根据相关的参数在模板库中
插入正确的同步来适配MMAD的一个正确的实线
第二个是需要增强FixPipeL0C到L1通路
我们要实现通过微指令实现L0C到L1的一个正确的数据的搬运
好我们来具体看看
这是我们主要的一个整体的方案设计
那我们来看看具体我们每个PASS需要做一些什么
首先在Insert Load Store和MixTV中
我们要识别这个DOT加DOT的一个具体的优化的场景
只有在这个正确的场景下我们才做这个优化
这个场景是指什么呢
它是指第一个DOT的旅造的旅造只做第二个DOT的operant
它只是第二个DOT是第一个DOT旅造的唯一的一个优责
如果第一个DOT不但被第二个DOT使用
还有还被Vector使用的话
它无论如何都会失落到节目中
这样我们这个优化就上市的意义
第二个还是要第二个是需要考虑
FIXPipe实际上的硬件能力
实际上在生存硬件中FIXPipe
它是对数据类型转换是有明确的要求的
像FIXPipe它只能将F32的数据
然后从L0C搬运到L1
它只是支持固定的格式的数据转换
比如说F32到F16
F32到BF16这种数据格式类型是支持的
像F32到F32这种数据格式
它是不支持这种水路转换的
所以我们要考虑我们的算子的数据类型
是否正确的合乎要求
如果不合乎要求的话
我们也不做这个优化
第二个是看Growth Server
我们需要新增四个参数
其中第一组是FIXPipe
跟L1跟MT的一个正向同步
第二组是FIXPipe
跟MT的一个反向同步
我们可以具体看这张图
首先MMAD是一个红指令
我们在做一个DOT的时候
在原型的路径中
首先是把DOT所需要的数据
从GM通过MT2搬运到L1Buffer上
然后MT再将L1的Buffer上的A
两个OPER上的数据搬运到L0A跟L0C
然后再通过Cube核心运算
然后结果输出到L0C上
然后在原本的通过Cube核心运算
然后在原本的通路中L0C会将数据
重新搬运到GM
再进行一个循环的过程
然后因为我们生成芯片
6个流水是能够并行工作的
然后这个数据上就会有一些依赖
那么我们就要在MMAD的过程中
我们就要需要保证MT2将我所有的数据搬运到L1上
然后我才MT1才能将数据搬运到L0C上
做一个数据运算
即我L1的如果我MT2把数据准备完成了
我需要发送一个同步的Event实践
告诉MT1告诉我数据已经Ready了
然后你们再可以进行一个下一次的搬运
然后第二个是在DoubleBuffer的条件下
我们会循环的进行这种MultiBuffer的迁换
那么我MT1消费完了L1的数据之后
我要通知MT2我的数据已经消费完了
那么MT2可以搬移新一组的数据到L1上
原先是原先只有GM到L1的一个数据通路
那我们新增了FixPipeL0C到L1上的通路
那么同理我要需要增加FixPipe
WaytL0AEvent跟FixPipeFixWaytL1BEvent两个事件
来同步MT1跟FixPipe
用于告诉MT1我FixPipe已经将数据准备Ready了
你可以继续进行下一步的搬运
然后后面也是同理可以知道MT1需要两个事件
告诉FixPipe我的L1上的数据已经被消耗完毕了
那么FixPipe可以进行下一组数据的搬运
这是一个在同步方面上的一个主要修改
然后不但要增加这四个Event来进行同步
而且需要区分L1上的数据的原目Pipe到底是FixPipe
还是MTR将对应的EventID的事件插入对应的槽位来正确的处理同步关系
然后进同步完成之后
我们还需要做一个模板库的适配
首先MMAD红指令在Convented to Standard之后
它会转化成一个LibCore
这个LibCore最后对应的会是在Authanas NPOIR实现的一些模板库函数
这种模板库函数就包含了底层硬线
底层硬件上的一些intristic的一些具体的实现
在原本的一个MMT1Tile的实现中
我们发现它有7个参数
主要是这4个参数
主要是MT1跟MTR的一个同步参数
然后其余几个是FixPipe的DoubleCouple的Condition
和Backup的Pipe ML0C上的一些Event和同步的关系
我们这些都不设计
由于我们增加了FixPipe的同步
所以我们在新修改的实现中
我们增加了FixWaitLeEvent
FixWaitLeBEvent
FixReleaseFixLeAReleaseFixEvent
跟LeBReleaseFixEvent
这4个参数来用于FixPipe的实现
由于MMAD这个函数比较复杂
它里面还需要增加一些同步相关的适配
所以这里我就没有在这里放了
第二个是需要增加一个FixPipe
L0C到L1的实现
在原本的FixPipe的模板库里面是没有一个数据
L0C到L1的一个数据通路的
这个需要我们自己实现
我们需要自己注册相关的Lib Core函数到
Ascend MPOI的模板库中
并且通过自己通过Intristic实现L0C到L1的搬运
在里面我们主要是用这一条Coffee Matrix
CC2CBuff这一条指令
来进行一个L0C到L1上的一个搬运
对于Intristic有兴趣的同学可以参观
参阅CNN社区相关有Isa的一些指令接口的具体的含义
包括在CNN的看包底下也有相关的一些Intristic的要用示例
包含Ascend MPOI的一些模板库都是一些很好的参考来源
来进行一些Intristic的高级的一些hack
然后我们完成了这一部分之后
我们可以看一下一个具体的实际用力
和中间一些IR转换PASS的一些过程和一个整体的加速情况
我们可以看一看这个实际的一个DOT+DOT的一个kernel
我们首先把BC从节目上load出来
然后做一个DOT
DOT之后我们再进行一个旅路
旅路之后再进行一个第二次的DOT
然后再把结果写回到节目中
我们可以看到在convorder toStand PASS之前
我截取了部分IR
我们可以看到这两个FIXPIP是不一样的
第一个是FIXPIP是从L0C搬运到L1
我们可以看到它是没有一个DMA的MOD的
并且它有一个旅路的MOD
就是我们这个LibDevice的一个旅路
还有它的MEMF是CC-CBUFF的
第二个FIXPIP它是有一个DMAMOD的
是从Nz格式转换到Nd格式的
然后它的一个下落
它通过ComponentStandard之后
它是下降到两个不同的函数的
第一个函数就是我们刚刚在模板库函数
新增的一个适配
FixPipeCBuff Normal Float to Hub 4D to 4D
第二个函数
第二个FixPipe则是它原本的一个模板库的实现
FixPipe NZ to ND Float to Hub 4D to 2D的一个实现
然后我们经过测试看到
可以看到在这个简单的Case中
我们通过编译器的L0C到L1的一个优化路径的打通
我们是得到了13%的一个性能提升
好
那我们继续第二个章节
如果使用Component来进行
直到编译器进行优化
首先我们想介绍一个
Disable Bubble Up的一个Compile Hint的属性
在介绍这个Hint之前
我们首先来了解一下什么是Bubble Up
首先我们来看一下
Bubble Up的一个在ChatenAdapter中的一个具体的位置
它是在ChatenAdapter之后来进行一个Bubble Up的提升
来消除一些
主要是处理一些非连续性仿存的一些优化
Bubble Up首先是将Tensor Extract
上推其生产者的操作的输入车
将整个完整Tensor的计算
转后往基于远处或切片的局部计算
从而降低农余的Tensor级的计算
为后续的标量及Ostract Learning
提供更规整的一个L的形式
可能这一段话大家听的都比较云里互联
我们可以看一个简单的例子
它其实主要是将两个Tensor加起来
然后如果后面只是取这个Tensor的一部分的话
那我就可以将它转化成
我只取原本的这一个Tensor的一部分
先取出来再做一个计算
它这样是有什么好处呢
它首先降低了一个UB的使用
UB的内存的上升的占用
原先如果是计算一个128
两个128的Tensor
它会额外的产生一个128的一个中间结果的Tensor
然后如果我转化成一个经过BubbleUp
我把这个原本的整个的Tensor级别的加法给消除了
我只有一个Scalar或者局部Tensor的计算
这样显著就降低了一个内存
一个UB的占用
并且它还降低了计算强度
如果是下面
如果这个只是一个Scalar的计算的话
那我只需要把两个Scalar给取出来
然后最后做一个加法
这个计算量只是一个Scalar
如果我们是没有进行一个BubbleUp的优化的话
它会做整个128个的一个向量计算
这个计算强度也是显然比BubbleUp要高的
所以我们会有一个BubbleUp的优化来通来
降低计算强度和减少UB的占用
但是这个BubbleUp的优化不是任何时候都是有效的
我们可以看一个具体的Normalize的例子
在这个例子中
首先我们做了一个Normalize
然后再乘一个Wait
然后我们再把Normalize的结果存储到Output中
然后如果是PagerTention的情况下
我们需要把这个Output重新写回到PagerTention的Cache中
在这个例子中我们发现这个Y无论如何都要计算
并且无论如何都要进行一个UB的占用
然后在这种情况下
我们就没有办法去既不能避免这个运算的强度
也不能减少内存的占用
在我们如果继续做一个这样BubbleUp的优化
那么他会在下面重建整个Normalize的一个计算
他会把这些一块的YI整个的提取出来
然后再做一个Normalize
再做一个触发
再做一个MAT
然后再把它Store回来
他这个主要的原因
因为他这个本身就是一个连续性的摊摄操作
它的离散的原因不是因为我这里需要提取一个slash
而是因为计算PagerTention的时候
它这个index的值是离散的
所以他并在这种条件下
他就不适用这种多化
他反而会引入一些计算强度的增加
引入一些额外的计算
这些额外的计算
会引入一些额外的同步
所以它的性能会下降的比较厉害
在我们disable这个BubbleUp
BubbleUp的使用
disableBubbleUp这个hint的条件下
我们是获得了10%的性能提升
然后使用这个hint也是非常的简单
你看它的一个具体的用法
只需要用一个V字语句
然后tl1hintDisableBubbleUp
然后就会自动的把这个well load
就不再做一个BubbleUp的提升
然后我们也可以看一下中间ml
它的经过BubbleUp之后
我们可以看到它的一些reload
它中间多了很多没有必要的reload
然后还有一些格式的一个因为生存芯片
数据类型格式的一些知识情况
它额外引入了一些trunk和expand的一些拓展
这样都会导致我们性能的一个下降
我们来继续介绍第二个tl1hint
interNoEliance等数
interNoEliance的提示标记
主要是告诉编辑器某些interBuffer不存在别名
就是说不存在一些数据上的依赖
然后在两次的不同迭代间的store之间
它们不会产生一个写写冲突
为了保证产生写冲突的插入一些同步的barrel
然后我们是为了消除这个barrel
来用这个hint来做一下
我们可以看到
就与这下面这个例子来举例
我们这个offsetKVCache
是通过Extra的indexVariament来提取的
它是一个在阶段上内存的一个值
我们并不知道这一个值是否加上它的那一段rand
它是运行时才来确定它到底是不是有内存上的重叠
这个编译器是无法通过别名分析得到正确的结果的
但是因为我们是算纸的用户
我们在高层的时候我们在写算纸的时候就知道
我这些KVCache都是肯定是存储在配局中的不同位置
它天然就不会有一个写冲突
我们就可以用这个TLE的hint来告诉编译器
这些store这些copy之间
不会有一个内存冲突的情况
那么我就不需要再插入一个
HIMPipe Burial MTE的这个Pipe
来防止我这些写写冲突
来减少这些同步
然后是我们的指令能够在MTE上高效的并行起来
大概使用这个hint之后
我们大约能提升6%的一个形成
好了
讲完两个compile hint之后
我们再来讲一讲CustomOP
尽管我们可以通过修改编译器
和通过增加一些编译器的优化提示
来使编译器更好的编译算子
使它下降到一个更高效的实现
更高效的更高效的二进制的汇编码
但是编译器总是落后于芯片的一个发展
芯片的硬件的intristic
总是更快与编译器比编译器更早出现
并且编译器的能力始终是有限度的
那如果我们想利用
要通过汇编或者说intristic级别的一些硬件指令
来得到更高的加速的一个性能
并且更高得到一个更极致的性能
我们势必都想用一些更底层的intristic
来提升一些算子的性能
然后还有一个就是我们
我们同样的确译算子和确译算子
同样也提供了Custom OP这一套机制
供大家来实现自己的私有的更高效的更底层的一些算子
然后通过自己注册的Custom OP跟原本的确译算子的一个混用
来得到更高
高性能的一些算子
然后我们来大概看一看CustomMe的一个
一个RAW0
大概的一个RAW路径和它的一个具体的用法
首先我们需要注册一个CustomMe
这个CustomMe会在
ChairTownSender的RAW0路径中
转化成HVMCustom的一个OP
它会附带一个Name和一些attribute
包括它的一些in/auth的输出
然后在HVM2Standard的一个Path中
如果你是原本的ChairTown
自己的一些算子或者HVM原生的一些OP的WAR
它会调用原本的内置库的一个函数实线
它会Rolling到原本的一些内置库的一个LibCore上去
其实我们刚刚可以看到
分享中看到的NPOIR的一些模板库的实线
如果是用户提供的实线的话
它会转化通过注册的Custom的用户名
转化到一个特殊的Custom的一个LibCore
然后再跟用户提供的一些
一些一个CustomBC
就是用户自己实现的一个算子库
Link起来
最终编译成能够正确运行
在芯片上的一个2进制的一个文件
它是一个整体的架构和设计就是这样子的
那我们来看一下一个我们同样一个具体的场景和视力
和视力来看如何使用CustomOP
和CustomOP能获取什么样的性能
我们来讲一个比较大家都可能比较熟悉
Deepseek中的一个SFA的算子
Spicy Flash Attention的一个算子
我们可以看到Spicy Flash Attention的
Spicy的主要含应就是Q
不再是跟所有的K
要含应就是Q
做一个Attention计算
它只是跟部分的K
从K抽取部分的吸出行
与Q矩阵做一个注意力层
那么在PageAttention的条件下
Spicy的Index是指向多个Page的行
我们需要做一个Gather
把多行的离散的一个K
组成一个连续的TileSetD的KTile
供Cube进行DOT的使用
我们可以看到
在原本的一个编译器的路径的实现上
它首先要把K从离散的Page中
Gather到UB
通过Gather到UB
然后UB汇聚成一个连续的整块的一个TileK
然后在Store到Gem上
然后再从Gem上Load到L1上
再与Q做一个DOT运算
那么可以看到这个路径是很长的
它首先会有一个数据连续的一个农移的搬运
首先要把数据搬运到UB
UB再Store到Gem
再把Gem的数据重新搬运到L1
这个是有非常多的
容易的数据搬运
第二个很大的问题是它会挤占UB的空间
因为Gather在UB上进行一个Gather的话
那么K
KTile它会占用在会占用宝贵的UB的空间
它会导致整个算子的TileK size极具的减小
然后导致一些离散的数据搬运跟Cube核心
跟Work核心的计算率
计算算率都利用率不满
这会带来显入的性能的一个开销
然后我们就计划通过注册一个GatherGem to
L1的一个CustomOP
直接将Key搬运到L1
这样我们就省去了这个Gem的中转
而且也不在需要也不在额外的占用UB的一个空间
能够极大的增加一些TileK的size
然后提升我们一个算子的气能
为什么我们我们继续看一下
编辑器其实做这个优化是不好做的
我们因为它做这个搬运的话
它是有一些数据类型和一些维度上的限制
所以我们才用CustomOP做
而且这样也更简单
很方便直接来看一下怎么做一个Gem
到L1的GatherLoad的一个方向收集
首先我们需要注册一个CustomOP
然后CustomOP
首先我们需要注册要告诉编辑器
要注册哪些接口呢
首先是要注册它的CoreType
然后表明它其实是这个CustomOP是在Cube核心上运转的
他主要是为了info为了编辑器正确的能够推转CustomOP的那个CoreType
第二个是要知道CustomOP主要是运行在哪一条流水上
我们是一个Gem到L1的一个搬运
那么它主要是通过MTR这条Pipe来实现的
所以我们也是把它注册为MTR的一个PEF
第三个是一个MOD
现在主要因为我们是920C的一个芯片
而且主要是SMD的一个价格
所以我们把这个MOD也注册成SMD
这里我还没有可能没有写权
它还要注册要约定好Custom的一个具体的一个参数
它的参数要对
还有一个BC文件的路径和BCCore
一个Custom实现的一个Core文件的名和路径
然后我们在CustomOP的内部统一去完成一个Spicy Index的Load
然后把对应的相关行的一些间接捧存的一些配局的
腾讯中的KID需要搬运的KID地址
跟我需要存储的存储在L1上存储的一些L1上Cache的地址
给计算出来
然后调用底层的NZ的一个intristic
一个intristic来完成Gem到L1上的一个搬运
我们整体是需要做大体的方案设计就是这样的
那我们来具体看一下我们要怎么做
首先我们需要比较重要的一个核心
就是编写我们的一个CustomGetGem2L1的一个实现
首先我们要把必要的参数像Gem上的Key
还有一些Index
还有一些Page的一些Table
Spicy的一些Offset
BlockTable的一些参数
还有你的Table开始的一些基础位置
还有BlockSize
还有你最多的知识的一些BlockSize
跟你要最后要搬运的TableSize
CoreSize给传递进去
然后经过一些地址的计算
我们通过一个Fore循环把对应的在Gem上的单行的一个Source的Low的一个机子地址
跟在L1上的一个连续的一个TileKey的地址给它计算出来
然后通过调用CopyGM2CBubbD2NZ的一个Intritic进行一个数据的Gether
然后再完成了一个核心的一个呼喊度的实现之后
我们需要通过调用CCEC的编译器
将其编译成一个.bc的文件
我们通常都是通过CCEC的这一组命令
来将它编译成一个bc文件
这个bc文件
最后需要加入到我们的一个PACE的路径
然后最后在编译我们原生的算折的时候
再把这个bc文件跟我们原美的一个模板括的一些模板文件
最后link在一起形成最终的二精子
我们主要是要确定一个比较关键的几个点
就是首先我们要比较了解整个的一个编译的路径
路径的一个实现
我们要保证这些rolling的过程一致
如果不一致的话
可能会发现发生一些其他的错误
第二个是我们在这个函数中
需要正确的处理一些index的offset的正确的映射
这个主要是一个scalas的指令
第三个是你要正确的把通过调用正确的intristic
把我们需要关键的数据搬运到正确的地方
然后我们来看一下一个真实的用力
首先我们来看一下这是我们编写的一个简单的
Spicy QK的一个基础性的
我们可以看到一下
首先我们要注册一个Custom的一个OP
在Custom一种这个是CustomOP的一个名字
然后对应的Core是我们需要是在CubeCore上
Pipe是一个MT2的Pipe
然后Model是一个SIMD的一个Model
然后通过Ani的函数则申明了这个函数的一个参数的一个个数
跟一个参数我们需要参数的一个类型
第三个我们是有一个符号
第四个还有一个就是它的为它的酷编译好的酷函数的一个名称
那名字get-to-le to-bc就是我们刚才编写的一个酷函数的实现的一个编译成一个bc名
我们可以看一下Spicy QK一个整体的一个算子吧
它是怎么做的
首先我们可以看
首先是漏的一个足够的K
漏的一个Q
这个Q一般来说都是连续的
然后我们首先是需要一个把我们需要gather到的一个tag给分配出来
然后我们计算一下我们大概需要多少个tag
然后在K中通过Maker Brokeptr的接口告诉Customer
OP这个原硕士的K是一个具体的shape
它主要是K在gm上的一个地址
然后第二个是Spicy
Base的一个base的一个地址
还有一个是配具attention的一个block table的地址
还有一个Spicy的一个offset
它有多少offset
然后一个block table的based offset
然后还有一个我们tile star的一个地址
然后一个是配具attention中的一个block size
然后我们最多每batch是有多少个block
然后一个stride
然后你最后需要gather出来的一个tile
k的tile size
还有一个最后一维的一个dimision的一个维度
然后一个output的tile
然后我们整个的一个用法就是tile
直接调用一个al.customer
gathergm2le
然后通过我们上面的一个bitcode的链接
那么它就会正确编写出一个二进制文件
然后运行在深层上
通过我们这个性能优化
在真实的一个sfa的freshattention的算子中
我们在tile上有一个tile
然后我们整个的一个用法就是tile
直接调用一个al.customer
就是文件然后运行在深层canal上
通过我们这个性能优化
在真实的一个sfa的freshattention的算子中
我们在tile size扩大了几倍
并且我们是得到了一个1.85x的一个性能提升
然后这就是customerop的一个介绍
然后customerop它还有它一个比较大的限制
customerop是一个比较比较一个比较有效的一个hack的竞争
大家如果想利用深腾一些底层的intristic进行一些高性能算子的hack
都可以考虑用customerop的这一套接口来进行一些高高度定制的油画
或者说一些比较极端比较hack的一些油画
然后我们继续介绍一个稍微简单一点的一个ub insert slice的一个toe的insert slice的一个操作
它的主要是减少在ub上的一个内存的up上减少一个gem的load
它可以在ub上进行一些slice和拼接的操作
在我们spaxykvgator的kernel中
如果你想把krope跟krope选择位置编码的部分拼接起来
在原本的用原生的chater的一些语言拓展它是没有办法做到的
它只能通过两次分离的store将k跟krope分别store到节目上对应的位置
来完成一个k跟krope的一个拼接
这样会导致我们有多余一次的节目的store
不但我们有一个多余的store
它会带来一些离散数据搬运的一些开销
第一个是像kdim它通常是512
然后krope它通常是64
那么一次store512个数据跟再一次store64个数据
这是一个典型的离散的一个数据搬运的一个场景
其实lo的store一个51
一次lo的512个数据跟一次store512加64
576个数据的cost基本上是一致的
所以第二次store其实基本上很多时候是容易的
而且两次store它会导致一个同步的开销
它会消耗多它会多消耗一个同步的应用耐力
这样也可能会带来一些额外的同步的开销
然后我们在TLE的DSA的拓展中引入了insert slice这个操作
可以直接在ub上就完成k和krope的拼接
然后再一次把4k store到gm
这样我们就可以减少多余的一次gm的store
然后也减少了相关的同步
我们来大概看一下整个的用法
首先我们把整个4kbrokdkdm跟blockdkdm加起来
作为一个整体ub上的一个分配一个tensor
然后我们再把我们的k的vector部分插入到4k的一个对应的位置
然后具体的size是blockdkdm的1
然后我们再把4kdmdkdm插入到4k中
然后我们可以看到它整个的一个offset
从blockdkdm的这个位置开始插入
然后一个size是blockdkdm加blockdkrope的一个dm
这样我们就把两个ub上的kdm跟kropedm在ub上就完成了一个拼接
然后我们直接把这个forkey做到节目上
这样我们就减少了这一次的这一次的多余的store
然后提升了一个效率
然后我们可以看到经过insert跟slice的操作
我们得到了在这种简单的算子上
我们是得到了一个6%的提升
然后insert和slice在进行一些数据上的拼接
跟将离散绑存变成一个点续的绑存上
都是一些比较有用的一些操作的
我们可以多用一个在碰到一些离散的绑存的问题
或者离散的数据搬运的时候
我们都可以尝试使用这个接口来避免
来避免一些离散搬运
数据离散搬运的一些引入的一些额外的cost的开销
然后这个也不仅仅是在生存系面上有这个拓展
在其他的dsa的系面上
也是可以用insertslice跟extractslice拓展
然后我们今天主要的分享的内容都已经差不多结束了
我们在最后分享总结一下
我们首先可以通过优化编译器
然后使能20c-1的路径来完成一个算子的一个优化
就是说我们首先可以通过优化编译器来做一个算子性能的提升
第二个是我们可以通过一些compare hint
来告诉编译器进行一些特定的优化
或者说进行一些特定的不必要的优化
来告诉编译器一些额外的信息来指导算子优化
第三个,我们可以利用而生的npoi
而生的npoi跟确认而生的提供的custom的op的一个机制
然后注册我们自己私有的一些高性能的intristic实现的那个op算子
op库通过再将这些这些自定义的算子跟原本的算子混合使用
来得到我们一个更高性能的算子
第四个是可以用一些比较好用的tl的拓展来在ub上完成一些数据上的拼接
和一些在ub上进行一些数据拼接
来避免一些离散性的绑存带来的性能开销
好的,我们本次直播的主要要分享的内容已经差不多结束了
好,我们可以关注一下
flex
可以
我们可以首先关注一下我们flexOS开源社区的一些项目地址
有兴趣可以
克隆一下这个项目
follow一下
看看它里面有哪些比较好用的tl拓展
然后我们还有一个二维码可以关注一下Bless最近的一些信息
另外我们也可以扫码CNN的一些社区
看一些看训练员一些优秀的一些分享的一些资料和文档来提高我们编写生存算子的能力
好的,最后我们的一个直播主要内容分享就结束了
然后我们介绍的玩法一已经有相关的小伙伴在一休月进行评论答案了
那么我们本次直播三道题的答案分别是DBB
那么评论区全部答对的前五名的小伙伴可以私信我们的一个小助手领取奖品
然后没有抽到奖品的小伙伴也不要灰心
可以通过课外作业和学习笔记都会有机会拿到我们的奖品
大家也可以扫码报名CNN训练营更多的挑战和丰富的奖品
也等着大家也可以扫码屏幕上的二维码来观看下一场直播
然后我们也可以在B站上的搜索生存CNN观看回放
好,以上就是今天玛丽全开的直播的全部内容
我们下期再见